step three will begin no earlier than  the 17th  of may provided the data satisfies the  four tests most restrictions on meetings  outdoors will be lifted subject to a  limit of 30  and this is the point when you will be  able to see your friends and family  indoors subject to the rule six or the  meeting of two households we will also  reopen pubs and restaurants indoors  along with cinemas and children's play  areas  hotels hostels and bnbs  theaters and concert halls will reopen  their doors  and the turnstiles of our sports stadia  will once again  rotate subject in all cases to capacity  limits  depending on the size of the venue and  we will pilot  larger events using enhanced testing  with the ambition of further easing of  restrictions  in the next step